[Music]
I was like this reminds me of Drew so
I'm gonna wear it
[Laughter]
no Evan because every time we've done
the show it's like been virtual because
you know we launched in a pandemic yeah
but we're still here there you're here
you're crushing it
we're still here so that you could have
your own talk show I'm not kidding you
want to do it yeah sure I'm down I'd
like to give you the show okay in fact
Vanessa take it away
so last time we talked
um I feel like you wanted to talk to me
about like dating advice and sliding
into the DMS so my question to you is
have you been sliding in any Dems how is
that going for you so I haven't been
hiding into DMS but I did get back on my
dating app and I went on some dates here
and there okay felt like a big effort
and fun like yeah you know to follow
through not that the time spent was an
effort but just to you know engage out
there in the world not stay home
um don't think anything's clicking but
I'm you know don't know what how what
else rush it I mean like since I've seen
you yes you got it
[Applause]
thank you
and he's so nice
I know he still gets me yeah oh God he's
so nice to you and he just appreciates
you and he seems to see you for who you
really are yeah and and just appreciates
you and loves you like that does it for
me that's a plenty enough to see his
left are you guys planning a wedding
like yeah how's it going it's it's hard
I don't know finding a venue is tough I
kind of just want a lope I really I'm
lost I don't know does he have any
opinions I mean he just wants to get
married to me like he's like whatever
you want babe
um okay now I'm gonna take us a little
off topic oh my God I love you is this a
this is kind of like random but do you
believe in spirits or are you a skeptic
I think I'm a little bit skeptical have
you ever had like an encounter or like a
moment where you're like that was weird
or the the hairs on my arm are all
standing up and something's off I
I definitely believe in energy yeah and
I think energy can have a very big
physical impact
um as far as like hair standing up and
um like a cold breeze and all the things
that I usually attribute to spirits and
ghosts
um but I don't know if I've
like here's an example
um I know I've walked into places and
literally said get out like you have to
get out if you're something very
upsetting has happened here totally what
is that I mean I feel like trauma leaves
an imprint on space
but we have to go to a break and when we
come back we are going to be chatting
about my new documentary dead hot here's
a sneak peek
okay let's go this bad boy album
is anyone here that wants to speak to us
[Music]
God these dolls are so creepy
does anyone here
oh my God B what I just caught something
[Music]
foreign